وفي تطورات التصعيد الاسرائيلي بالضفه
الغربيه اعلنت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه
ارتفاع عدد الشهداء بمدن الضفه الغربيه
امس الاحد الى خمسه بعد استشار شابين
برصاص قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي عند
المدخل الشمالي لمحافظه رام الله والبيره
وافادت الوزاره بان الفتى سليمان كنعان
استشهد اثر اصابته بالرصاص الحي المباشر
في القلب بينما ابلغت سلطات الاحتلال
الجانب الفلسطيني باستشهاد واحتجاج ال
خالد حميدات دون اي تفاصيل وبذلك يبلغ عدد
الشهداء في الضفه الغربيه منذ السابع من
اكتوبر الماضي
352 ضب الينا من رام الله مراسل الجزيره
محمد خيري محمد قبل نصف ساعه وردت تقارير
عن اقتحامات جديده لقوات الاحتلال في
مناطق متفرقه من الضفه الغربيه اطلعنا على
التطورات نعم وهذه هي الاقت حمات الليليه
الاسرائيليه المستمره بشكل يومي منذ
السابع من اكتوبر وحتى هذا اليوم في اخر
التطورات اقتحمت قوات اسرائيليه كبيره
مدينه قلقيليه شمالي الضفه الغربيه من عده
محاور ودخلت مع هذه القوات جرافتين
واعلمنا ان القوات الاسرائيليه والجرافات
تحاصر منزلا في منطقه خله ياسين شمالي
المدينه في هذه الاثناء في الاثناء ايضا
اقتحمت قوات اسرائيليه كبيره ايضا مدينه
اريحا وهذه القوات ايضا ترافقها جرافات
حتى الان لا معلومات عن توجه هذه الجرافات
الى مكان بعينه لكن عندما ترافق قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الجرافات فان هناك
عمليات تخريب تجريها هذه الجرافات اما في
الشوارع والاحياء او بغرض هدم احد المنازل
في المناطق المقتحمه اليوم ايضا استشهد في
الضفه الغربيه خمسه شهداء من ضمنهم الثلاث
ثه اطفال استشهد اثنان منهما في بلده
البيري واحد هؤلاء لا تزال قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي تحتجز جثمانه حتى هذه اللحظه
وكذلك استشهد شابين ايضا في بلده سعير في
مدينه الخليل هؤلاء هذان الشابين كانا في
رحله للصيد في احدى المناطق كما افادنا
شهود عيان وكذلك روايات رسميه فلسطينيه
ولكن احد المستوطنين استدعى قو وتابعه
لجيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي التي كما يبدو
لم تتوانى باطلاق النار الحي تجاه الشابين
ما ادى الى استشهادهما على الفور الضفه
الغربيه تشهد لا تزال عمليات اقتحام
مستمره ومتواصله في جنوب الضفه الغربيه
وشمالها من قبل قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
للمدن والمخيمات والقرى الفلسطينيه وكذلك
لا تزال تنتشر الحواجز الاسرائيليه في
مناطق واسعه وتو وهي هي فعليا تقطع
الاواصر بين المدن والقرى والمخيمات في
الضفه الغربيه وخاصه بين المدن تحديدا و
يعني تعيق عمليه وحركه الفلسطينيين في
الضفه الغربيه وعدد الشهداء ارتفع حتى هذا
اليوم مع الشهداء الخمسه هذا اليوم الى
352 شهيدا في الضفه الغربيه منذ السابع في
من اكتوبر وحتى هذا اليوم التصعيد
الاسرائيلي مستمر في الضفه الغربيه ويبدو
ان مدينه قلقيليه تشهد حاله من التصعيد
التي شهدت حاله من تصعيد المستمر خلال
الفتره الماضيه تشهد تصعيدا كبيرا هذه
الليله خاصه في ظل استمرار محاصره المنزل
المذكور بمرافقه الجرافات الاسرائيليه
الانباء تشير الى ان اريحا ايضا دخلتها
قوات اسرائيليه في العاده وخلال ساعات
الليل تقتحم القوات الاسرائيليه المدن
والمخيمات تحديدا وتشتبك مع المقاومين
الفلسطينيين وكذلك في بعض الاحيان مع
المواطنين الفلسطينيين وتطلق الرصاص الحي
باتجاه المواطنين الفلسطينيين سنتابع
التطورات في قلقيليه واريحا وعموم الضفه
الغربيه ونوافير شكرا لك محمد خيري في رام
الله